traditionally where people have used
compute in their their research they
know what to do because they've they're
experts in the field and a lot of our
classical users using HPC know exactly
what they want they know how to process
their data they know they need to use
scientific Linux they can write software
to process their data and they can get
their own research questions answered by
themselves and you know part of
information services job is simply just
to provide the hardware in the grunt
that they need to do that but
increasingly we're finding that other
people are wanting to use compute in
their research but they're not really
knowing how they haven't got those
skills so part of my role is to sort of
link up their research problem with the
skills needs the software and the
analysis tools that they need to you
know answer their questions I was a
medicinal chemist so that's a type of
synthetic chemist who designs and makes
new drugs so all the different processes
through you know designing a small
molecule for a particular drug target
doing some computational docking using
the hpc to find out of the million
possibilities which ten should I make
and then test to see which might be the
cure for cancer asthma Alzheimer's
disease or just the new painkiller I
started off my training doing a PhD in
chemistry just the simple how do you
make this compound what reagents to use
how do you make it but as I sort of
progressed in my career moved into the
drug discovery space where the
chemistry's just applied as the
technique that's just one of the tools
and the the interesting and the
intelligent thing is this is the drug
target what should I make to interfere
with that target to have that biological
effect and my interest really looked it
moved into sort of the using computers
to answer those kind of questions so
what do we make why do we make it where
should we direct our efforts
traditionally in all style research it
would just be somebody sat in an office
thinking about a particular problem and
then proposing an answer but then you
know that as a scope and possibilities
they increase you know we've got more
data available we've got more
possibilities available it really
expands beyond what one person can hold
in their head so as research is
interdisciplinary and we use chemists
biologists engineers mathematicians so
that you know in a traditional submit'
like wet organic chemistry we now need
to use computers to help analyze
possibilities data and questions so yeah
kind of expanding that research space
into using computers is really sort of
becoming increasingly more important how
I got involved in HP pcs and computing
was doing something called docking so if
we have a small molecule of a drug
molecule say like aspirin or salbutamol
though we think might be a good
molecule in a particular drug target
what we can do is use the computer and
ask it a question saying does this small
drug molecule fit into this receptor
protein how good a fit is it where does
it fit in what shape is it when it fits
so what we can do is use specialist
software packages to ask that question
of hundreds of thousands or even
millions of small molecules so you will
prepare a question how well do these
five million drug molecules fit into
this receptor with the question with the
software I'll submit that question to
the HPC queue and the that's where the
HPC takes over and say okay this guy's
got this question that's broken down
into actually 25 million sub questions
and it's the HPC scheduler that then
splits that job up into separate Nords
and distributing out to different
processor cores so I could have 2,000
processor cores one working on each drug
molecule into that separate receptor
when it's finished with that one it will
tell this and a master controller that
it's done and it will be allocated the
next one to do so it's kind of like that
the HPC is acting as my research
assistant and answering all those
millions and millions of questions for
me while I'm in the lab making - or
having a cup of coffee or lunch or
chatting to the boss about what the next
question is that particular question
sounds like a very very complicated
puzzle really isn't it and it sounds
like a really complicated puzzle but
that the techniques and the software
tools for asking that question how well
does that molecule fit into there a very
mature it's very well known it's very
well understood a subject the problem is
really the scale and I can't have enough
computing power to dock every single
possible molecule into every single drug
target it's got to be an intelligent
choice but as computing power is ever
increasing you know Moore's law more
processors more memory I can ask more of
the computer get it to tell me more
information so I can concentrate on the
the chemistry specific knowledge I'm
imagining researchers from across the
university well certainly across the
world wanting to to use computers to do
these to answer these questions is there
one science that uses it more than
others or no I don't think there is
really I mean I think traditionally
users have come from physics astronomy
chemistry engineering in particular but
also increasingly biology genomics
researchers the life sciences and we're
now seeing people from the social
sciences humanity and even arts coming
in to start using computers in their
research and are these high-performance
computing systems or clusters are
becoming the norm are people expecting
these as part of their research now
absolutely yes you know again going back
years what we need to provide to an
academic
would be an office a desk a green board
and some chalk now people really expect
and you know that high performance
computing facilities are available to
them and the university does that by
providing HPC facilities like we're just
looking at today but also renting them
from cloud providers like Amazon and
Azure Microsoft and Google and others as
well thinking of those leaders of the
field Google and Amazon cloud computing
etc why would you do it yourself if all
those options are available was a number
of reasons we might want to do it
ourselves first and foremost those
companies are really good at it but most
companies are really good at it because
they charge for doing it so there is a
higher cost associated with renting
somebody else's kit to do it there are
times when we need to do it on-site for
security reasons so if we're working on
some very sensitive research material
maybe something in the medical field
with patient data we'll need to
guarantee to the funders and who owns
that data it's very safe and secure by
keeping it on-site equally we might be
doing something say with genomics
research where the quantity of data is
so vast in you know terabytes of data
per hour that we need to analyze it and
process it here on site and that the
costs and the time associated with
shipping that data somewhere else to
process it and answer those research
questions and then bring the data back
again is is prohibitive equal at those
times where we're using remote data say
satellite imagery or
data from the Human Genome Project well
that data already exists off in the
cloud so it makes far more sense there
for our researchers to take the question
to the data and analyze that data
off-site so kind of by offering both we
can hopefully give researchers the
ability to choose this one's better for
me or this one's better for me does it
ever go horribly wrong in that you ask a
question and you've made a mistake and
wasted hours and hours or days of HPC -
absolutely it's happened to me more
times than I care to mention one time in
particular I was doing those docking
small molecules as a drug mark targets
only a couple of hundred thousand there
was some sort of software error it
started churning out an ever-increasing
error file size of the error file went
through 300 gigabytes blocks the entire
system everybody else's jobs failed 20
or so people quite angry with me that I
just killed all of their research but
that kind of thing does happen in
research and I guess that's the that's
the computational equivalent of the
professor having an explosion in the lab
and spraying stuff all over the room
which I've also done maybe I'm in the
physics lab working with Professor
Moriarty and I want to do some computing
time how much it gonna cost me to use
that kit that's a good question
at the minute we don't actually charge
our researchers directly for using an
HPC facility so there's no per hour
charge for using a computer core you do
know this is going to be available for
them to all watch and then they're all
going to start clamoring after this
absolutely you know and if more people
need more resources and we can provide
them we can we can look to work for them
what we want our research to be
ambitious and to try and push the
boundaries and we can't do that by
restricting unnecessary access to kit if
money doesn't really come into it in
that way how do you decide who does what
and are there fights that erupt as to
who needs to compute power more than who
else there are vigorous discussions each
time we get a new HPC system and you
know you you you can see in there it's a
large HPC there are so many processor
cores and it can be used for such and
such a period of time and there's always
a debate about how much of it at any one
time is somebody allowed to use and how
long can any one person's job go on
through so very much like Tetris how can
I fit these variable width and size
blocks in
is it better for me to use a thousand
calls for 10 hours or 100 calls for many
thousands of hours and how do I fit that
workload it always causes vigorous
discussion few disagreements there's
always morning that the cues far too
long but that's just how it is
where does the book stop in terms of the
decision-making is it left at a software
world as a human come in and say every
time we sort of review the process a
group of humans will sit sit down and
decide okay we think it's fair if
everybody's allowed to run up to a
thousand cause for up to four days time
and we kind of sit down and make those
decisions as a research community and
then the software vigorously enforces
those limits for us so you are only
allowed up to so many hundreds or
thousands and your job is only allowed
to run for a maximum of four days and if
it goes over four days it stopped and
the next person's given access to that
resource in a way that could be limiting
research right it's something that the
researchers have got to trying to fit
into their research plans such as in the
same way that office space and
laboratory space can be a limiting
factor it's how do I divide my research
question up onto the computer am I
better using two thousand calls for a
short period of time or is it the kind
of question that is only limited to a
thousand cores and needs to run for a
longer period of time do you need to
know a fair bit about computing just to
make those decisions though
traditionally yes I think there has been
an expectation you have to know a lot
about how computers work to make those
decisions but we are seeing now as the
use of computers in research moves into
other areas part of my role is to try
and help people to understand how
computers think as computers work in a
very different way to a researcher they
know good at answering the same question
for a long period of time in parallel so
sort of changing how you would do it in
in person how you would add do some
calculations to how a computer would do
it lots of different things at the same
time it is a is a step change for some
people
the equipment itself is fairly generic
you know that these are standard blade
enclosures the storage is standard
storage we have about 240 terabytes in
this it's all connected up by a minivan